[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat de france 24
sixième jour de la guerre en ukraine et
la russie accentue son offensive la
capitale kiev devrait être la prochaine
cible une colonne de chars fait route
vers la ville elle est longue de plus de
60 km la tour de télévision de kiev a
été visé cet après midi par une frappe
russe les habitants de la capitale
restent terrés chez eux le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky a appelé à
l'aide les eurodéputés ne nous lâchez
pas at il lancé plus à l'est non loin de
la frontière russe kharkiv deuxième
fille d'ukraine est aussi la cible de
bombardements les ukrainiens sont de
plus en plus nombreux dans ce contexte a
tenté de fuir le pays sont déjà plus de
660 milles à s'être réfugiés dans les
pays voisins selon l'onu alors jusqu'où
peut aller cette offensive russe la
capitale kiev peut-elle tenir face à la
puissance de la deuxième armée du monde
comment l'aide humanitaire s'organise
pour les civils restés sur place et pour
ceux qui ont fuit on va en débattre avec
nos invités ce soir antoine à jacques
kossowski historien spécialiste de la
russie et de l'ukraine directeur de
recherche au collège des bernardins
auteur de voyage de saint pétersbourg à
moscou anatomy de l'âme russe aux
éditions el salvador antoine hachard à
jarque ski bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous également avec nous lucile
marbot porte parole du cicr en france
bonsoir gauthier rybinski chroniqueur
internationale pour france 24
et puis le général vincent desportes qui
doit nous rejoindre dans quelques
instants il est professeur de stratégie
à sciences po et hec ancien directeur de
l'école de guerre voilà merci beaucoup
en tout cas à tous d'avoir répondu
présent ce soir on va d'abord faire un
point j'aimerais sur la situation à kiev
alors que une offensive de très grande
ampleur semble imminente je vous le
disais la tour de télévision a été
touchée cet après midi par une frappe
russe tout la diffusion des chaînes a
été interrompu il y aurait au
cinq morts selon les services de secours
eux craignent un on voit ça tout de
suite en images
ces images ont été dévoilées cette nuit
par une société d'imagerie satellite
américaine
on y voit un interminable convoi russe
en file indienne des camions des blindés
par centaines se regroupaient approche
du nord de kiev
selon les informations américaines le
convoi s'étendrait sur près de 60 km
entre la ville de pris bir ce qu ils
aéroports antonoff
au sixième jour de l'opération russe
chacun sait dans la capitale ukrainienne
que la bataille de kiev approche dans
les rues des barricades sont dressées
aux entrées de la ville des panneaux
publicitaires préviennent soldats russes
ne devient pas un meurtrier va t'en
reste un humain peut-on lire ici
un peu plus loin un habitant expliquent
comment fabriquer des cocktails molotov
par duel de moteur et 2 par décence
[Musique]
malgré l'imposant dispositif russe ces
hommes qui ne sont pas des soldats de
métier se disent sûrs de leur force
nous accueillerons les russes avec des
cocktails molotov et des balles dans la
tête c'est ainsi que nous les
accueillerons il n'était pas autorisé à
venir ici je ne sais pas qu'il comptait
sauver ici
face à l'avancée russe beaucoup de ces
ukrainiens disent ne pas avoir d'autre
choix que de résister comme ce jeune
homme qui creuse en pleine nuit une
tranchée devant son immeuble
je dois la faire
je n'ai pas de casque je n'ai pas
d'équipement je me voilà en train de
creuser une tranchée au lieu de
simplement étudie et de vivre
normalement
personne ne sait encore quand aura lieu
exactement l'offensive russe
ce midi le président ukrainien a indiqué
que la défense de kiev était la priorité
pour le pays et on va justement
retrouver à kiev alexandre iv anguilles
à un entrepreneur français en mission
dans la capitale ukrainienne
alexandre quatre ans guy bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur france 24
une offensive de grande ampleur semble
imminent on imagine vos craintes est ce
que la télévision fonctionne encore
après cette frappe russe tout à l'heure
comment vous vous organiser alors oui là
j'étais tout à l'heure au centre-ville
moi je suis une rue derrière la place
maïdan je sais pas si on voit non peut
pas voir être le reflet j'étais tout à
l'heure de or là je suis rentré la
télévision fonctionne à nouveau'
apparemment la tour de la télévision
aurait été frappé mais pas entièrement
détruite donc la télévision fonctionne
les rues sont très calmes effectivement
on commence à voir ce qu'on voyait pas
la semaine dernière
des carrefours avec des sacs de sable
des croix en fer enfin des choses qui
sont faites pour bloquer les chars qui
pourrait sensiblement rentrée ou du
matériel militaire voilà comment un
petit peu l'ambiance ce soir lankaise
qui n'était pas encore il ya encore
quarante huit heures comment s'organise
votre quotidien depuis jeudi on imagine
que c'est très compliqué au centre ville
ça va alors j'ai beaucoup de gens qui
m'appellent sur le sujet aux abords de
kiev et dans les villes autour c'est
très très très très difficile pour les
gens au centre ville là où on est sur
maïdan écoulée chez stx à bas les
supermarchés étaient ouverts il ya de
l'approvisionnement on peut quand même
sortir il n'y a pas de grosse présence
militaire dans les rues mais beaucoup de
présence de miliciens de gens armés
c'était un petit peu tendu un petit peu
compliqué
mais on était relativement privilégié
jusqu'à maintenant par rapport à ce
qu'il ya en dehors de la ville est
évidemment dans la super jean yves le
drian le chef de la diplomatie française
a invité hier les français à quitter la
capitale ukrainienne par la route du sud
vous êtes resté c'est un choix vous
n'avez tout simplement pas réussi à fuir
non nous on était venu il ya une dizaine
de jours pour nos affaires nos dossiers
on avait prévu de rester on a fini le
dernier rendez-vous aujourd'hui on va
commencer à s'organiser demain après
demain pour quitter
non nous avons été prévenus il ya deux
jours seulement que l'aéroport de tous
les cas resterait fermée jusqu'au 27
mars c'est le mail qu'on a reçu les
compagnies aériennes donc la seule
possibilité pour l'instant de partir
c'est le train ou la voiture le train on
était allé se renseigner hier à la gare
effectivement il ya quand même pas mal
de trains mais il ya une foule c'est
terrible pour pouvoir monter dans les
trains et
la seule option qui reste c'est de
trouver des voitures des chauffeurs qui
sont prêts à prendre la route soit vers
l'est parlant vers l'ouest soit vers le
sud vous êtes en contact avec vos
proches en france et avec le quai
d'orsay
avec mes proches oui bien sûr tout à
fait whatsapp fait que l'on peut être en
contact rapidement avec mes proches qui
sont en france aux états unis en arabie
saoudite à bahreïn là où réside le quai
d'orsay n'ont pas vraiment je sais qu'il
ya une grosse polémique ici sur place
par rapport aux français résidents parce
que moi je suis pas mais eux mêmes il
suffit d'aller sur le compte twitter de
l'ambassade se plaignent du fait que
l'ambassade de france lors avait dit
depuis deux trois semaines restait
mettez vous à l'abri
etc et qu'ils ont découvert il ya 48
heures que l'ambassade elle même quitté
kiev pour aller dans une autre ville et
qu il leur disait que maintenant il
faudrait partir donc moi c'est le
sentiment que j'ai eu encore une fois
parce que j'habite pas ici mais les
français que je rencontre et qui m'ont
dit mais je comprends pas depuis deux
semaines trois semaines ont demandé une
assistance une évacuation même sur le
site de l'ambassade c'était resté qui
s'étaient inscrits qu'il fallait rester
se mettre à l'abri et aujourd'hui on
découvre que l'ambassade elle-même
quittent la ville et va s'installer
ailleurs et je crois que il ya quand
même pas mal de français qui sont
coincés ce soir mais non content à l'est
de même dans kiev et qui savent vraiment
pas du tout comment partir et vous avez
prévu de vous mettre ou à l'abri en cas
de bombardement
pour l'instant donc
merci beaucoup alexandre quatre ans guy
d'avoir été avec nous merci pour ce
témoignage sur france 4 général vincent
desportes vous nous avez rejoint je
rappelle que cette professeur de
stratégie à sciences po et hec ancien
directeur de l'école de guerre bonsoir
les habitants de kiev redoute de voir
des avions russes bombardé la ville on a
vu ce bombardement de la tour de
télévision tout à leurs bombardements
très symbolique clairement la russie
aujourd'hui à la une supériorité dans le
ciel ça risque de faire beaucoup de
victimes alors si la bataille de kiev de
kif commence ce sera une bataille t on
sait que monsieur poutine est capable de
retenue ce dont il a fait relativement
preuve jusqu'à aujourd'hui et puis il
est capable de l'absence totale de
retenue rappelons-nous qu'il a fait
raser grosse ni rappelons nous qu'il a
fait détruire des villes syriennes et
que son camarade assad donc il est
capable du pire les armées russes sont
capables de la plus grande violence
chacun a les images en tête et images de
la prise de moscou en 1945 donc si
jamais la bataille de kif été lancée
alors ça pourrait être terrible mais
évidemment cette bataille-là serait un
double échec l'échec de l'occident qui
aurait été incapable de l'empêcher et
l'échec de monsieur poutine qui n'est
pas parvenu à son objectif rapidement
comme il souhaitait le faire et non
seulement ce serait l'échec du monsieur
poutine mais probablement ce serait la
fin du régime poutine parce que très
probablement se serait l'afghanistan de
ce serait afghanistan de poutine comme
ça a été que neuf des listes en était la
femme de lui et de l'urss et donc ce que
ce que je pense c'est que monsieur
poutine
n'a pas envie de détruire kiev il n'a
pas envie sa grande faiblesse et il le
sait c'est son opinion publique et c'est
son armée qui est une armée de citoyens
russes qui ont bien le sentiment de
combattre contre les frères slave et
donc il sait bien que le temps joue
contre lui et qu une attaque massive et
destructrice contre la ville n'est pas
son avantage donc je pense que là il est
en train d'encercler la ville de manière
à montrer à l'occident nous avons nous
avons vu tous ces colonnes de chars il
est capable de prendre la ville et je
crois qu'il rajoute ça je crois qu'il
rajoute ça à la table des négociations
pour arriver lui-même a décroché de ce
conflit dont il ne peut pas sortir
gagnant s'il continue et diola et de
manière à ce que eh bien on rentre dans
une démarche qui lui permettent de
partir non pas avec les honneurs de la
guerre parce que ça c'est évidemment à
totalement impossible mais pour qu'il
puisse arrêter cette guerre sans risquer
son régime et sans risquer sa propre vie
ou côtier rybinski et il n'a pas envie
de détruire kiev vladimir poutine moi je
suis assez d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire le général desportes jeu mais je
pense que ça peut être une défaite
supplémentaire et de l'occident auquel
auquel cas parce que si effectivement
poutine met sur la table la prise ou la
non prise de kiev comme une espèce de
monnaie des changes je crains que
l'europe que les états unis se
satisfassent de cela en disant nous
évitons le pire nous invitons nous
évitons le bombardement de kiev nous
évitons la prise de l'ouest ukrainien
jusqu'à lui faire la frontière polonaise
satisfaisant nous deux cela et c'est ça
la complexité de la situation c'est que
malgré les sanctions l'impossibilité
d'une intervention militaire de l'ouest
pourri toutes les raisons que l'on
connaît cette impossibilité fait que
nous sommes potentiellement
susceptibles de nous satisfaire de
choses intermédiaires qui serait
inacceptable
c'est à dire que de fait ce serait
entériner l'invasion de l'ukraine que de
dire bon si vous ma cousine si vous ne
prenez pas kiev on va pouvoir s'arranger
le reste on le connaît le reste c'est
une maîtrise y compris terrestres de
l'armée russe jusqu'à peu près pas très
loin du nieppe qui passe à la verticale
de kiev antoine azar causes qu'ils
essayent de faire pression la poutine
sur sur les occidentaux avec ce qui est
en train de se passer en ce moment
oui ils essayent de faire pression mais
c'est une pression qui est vaine en
réalité ce qu'il montre aux ukrainiens
et ce qu'il montre monde occidental
c'est que alors que sa justification
d'envahir l'ukraine étaient entre
guillemets pour des nazifié le l'ukraine
ce qu'il fait est tout à fait comparable
à ce qu'ont fait les envahisseurs nazis
en 1941 est l'exemple le plus éminent de
cela c'est qu'aujourd'hui il a bombardé
babillard mabillard c'est un quartier de
kiev
ce sont des ravins ou en septembre 1941
les nazis sont arrivés et ont fusillé
des milliers de juifs c'est juste à côté
de cette tour de télévision c'est pas
très loin de la tour de télévision tout
à fait et c'est là où c'est cette bombe
et est tombé et a détruit le mémorial de
babi yar qui est vraiment le lieu de
mémoire par excellence de cette deuxième
guerre mondiale et de cette tragédie de
la shoah donc lui qui veut des nazis
fier le gouvernement ukrainien emploie
des méthodes encore plus sauvage que les
nazis donc il se décrédibilise
totalement auprès des ukrainiens il
aucune chance de tenir kiev ni
aujourd'hui ni demain mais il se
décrédibilise aussi auprès de sa
population parce que babillard et
plushenko a fait un poème sur babillard
que connaissent tous les russes parker
et donc il peut pas ça peut pas tenir ça
peut pas tenir une seconde mais oui à
supposer que pardonnez moi que les
russes aient l'information c'est une
autre alors voilà tout à fait le
problème c'est que la russie est en
train de débrancher twitter facebook etc
mais les gens sont habitués depuis des
années à trouver des sources
alternatives et en particulier il trouve
comme informations sur cnn il ya
quelques minutes que 400 missiles ont
été envoyés par la russie sur l'ukraine
4 100 missiles on n'est pas encore à
grozny je suis d'accord on n'est pas
encore à alep mais on est dans une
guerre sauvage on est dans une guerre
absolument d'une brutalité impensable et
encore quelques on a vu ce que jean rust
manifesté depuis jeudi malgré les
interdictions des autorités les russes
manifeste à saint pétersbourg et pas
simplement dans des tas de ville de
sibérie moi j'ai des amis qui me donnent
des informations là-dessus et les la
guerre n'est pas populaire poutine
pensait que face à toutes les
difficultés qu'il traverse en
particulier liés à la pandémie mais pas
uniquement toutes les difficultés
économiques et sociales il pourrait avec
une bonne guerre retrouver sa popularité
comme ça avait été le cas en 2014 au
moment de l'annexion d'un crime et et
son calcul est en train d'échouer
totalement l'aller les russes ne
soutiennent pas une guerre avec un un
peuple frère comme celui de l'ukraine
donc voilà
s'il marbot un siège de kiev si ça
venait à arriver ça signifie une
situation bien sûr très compliqué pour
les civils sur place comment agit le
cicr aujourd'hui à kiev vous êtes
présent aussi dans d'autres villes oui
en fait le cicr le comité international
de la croix rouge est présent en ukraine
depuis 2014 il y à 600 employés à
travers le territoire et donc c'est une
opération qui est conséquente ça faisait
déjà parmi les l'émission à les dix
premières missions au monde du cicr qui
oeuvre par ailleurs en syrie ou au yémen
beaucoup d'autres contextes de conflits
on est entendu là d' escalade récente
est extrêmement inquiétante depuis le
début ce que nous faisons c'est déjà un
dialogue directement avec les parties au
conflit pour leur rappeler leurs
obligations en termes de droit
international humanitaire on ne fait pas
n'importe quoi lorsqu'on combat c'est ce
droit est assez simple c'est vraiment
les principes distinction distinguer les
civils des militaires les
infrastructures civiles des
infrastructures militaires et des
l'instant bien entendu que la guerre est
amené dans des villes dans des zones
densément peuplées c'est d'autant plus
inquiétant et s'impose il ya le mal de
victimes civiles en économie et gagner
bien sûr la quiétude eux c'est qu'ils en
aient plus ce qui est des
infrastructures civiles nécessaire à la
population également qu'ils soient
endommagés donc c'est vraiment rappeler
aux belligérants la nécessité de
protéger des civils de faire attention
aux infrastructures nécessaires pour ces
la population des hôpitaux bien entendu
mais tout ce qui est réseau électrique
gaz ou eau tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est nécessaire pour donc aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment à rappeler ses
obligations également en termes d du
type d'armes employées qui ont bien
entendu en fonction des armes employées
ça va avoir plus ou moins un gros impact
en ville et sur les populations et
également de préserver nous permettre
nous acteurs humanitaires de travailler
aujourd'hui bien entendu les les besoins
augmentent on doit pouvoir répondre aux
besoins des populations et pour ça il
nous faut des accès sécurisés et donc
c'est vraiment de nous notre deuxième
priorité c'est vraiment de pouvoir
garantir un accès et de pouvoir assister
actuellement les populations on fait ce
qu'on peut aujourd'hui on a pu quand
même délivré à mario paul qui est notre
ville également il ya des combats
actuellement des kits de soin de secours
auprès de la croix-rouge ukrainienne qui
sont vos partenaires sur sur le terrain
il y a également des kits pour des
blessés de guerre qui sont prêts à être
livrés à kiev et de toute façon notre
réponse va malheureusement devoir
augmenter parce que les besoins sont pas
sans augmenter dans les jours qui
viennent en tout cas tout à l'heure
devant les eurodéputés le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky a appelé à
l'aide dont ils écoutent
cette terreur visa nous briser a brisé
notre résistance ils viennent dans notre
capitale comme ils l'ont fait à kharkhiv
la défense de la capitale est donc
aujourd'hui une priorité essentielle
pour l'état dans toutes les villes
l'ukraine doit faire tout son possible
pour arrêter l'ennemi
mais kiev c'est particulier si nous
défendons kiev nous défendrons l'état
qui est fait le coeur de l'ukraine il
doit battre il battra pour que la ville
puisse gagner
général vincent desportes les russes il
n'avait pas prévu une telle résistance
de la part des ukrainiens
c'est probable il est il est très
probable on n'est pas dans les plans de
l'armée russe mais il est très pro mini
résistance aussi pardonnez-moi consent
galvanisé aussi par par ce président
voulait dit melilla yahia il ya deux
choses
je pense que le plan russe était de
prendre grozny ans en est
maximale à
l'aide de prendre prendre kiev en 24
heures avec cette opération aéroportée
qui sont l'avoir été pris qui semblait
avoir été prévus seul aéroport dire
antonoff de manière à à rentrer à ne pas
avoir à pénétrer que des chars dans dans
kiev mais pouvoir projeter une opération
aéroportée et pouvoir se saisir
immédiatement avec les centaines
peut-être milliers que les deux soldats
que les gros porteurs auraient apporté
de kiev bon cette opération est là elle
a raté et depuis effectivement la
résistance
c'est qu'à venise et monsieur geslin ce
qui a été surpris comme tout le monde
dira que les axes qui rentrait de
biélorussie vers la l'ukraine en ville
n'avait pas été arrêté il n'y a pas de
fossé anti chars etc et se rejoint
heureusement je dirais 7 cet échec dans
la première bataille a permis d'une part
petit à petit à la ville de s'organiser
et d'autre part à monsieur zelensky de
montrer ce qu'on appelle désormais le le
le churchill le sud de l'ukraine mes
victimes je pense que ça va à la guerre
ce qui est important c'est les munitions
mais encore plus ce sont les forces
morales et il est évident que le leader
comme churchill d'ailleurs évidemment
avec du sang de sueur et de larmes le
leader farce une farce aux ukrainiens en
selle et s'étend sur place s'est refusé
d'être avec des mots qu'on connaît par
exemple c'est ça non je n'ai pas vu un
taxi j'ai besoin d'armes c'est comme ça
qu'on crée un récit national c'est comme
ça qu'on galvanise et c'est pour ça que
je pense que moi il partira pas il
partira pas il partira pas l'ukraine
parce qu'il est il est là il aurait il a
la responsabilité d'ailleurs la fierté
sûrement d'être l'âme de l'ukraine
aujourd'hui antoine hachard costil est
l'âme de migraines aux aujourd'hui
volodymyr zelensky oui clairement parce
qu'il défend l'ukraine je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit mais aussi il est l'âme de
l'ukraine parce qu'aujourd'hui il s'est
adressé au parlement européen avec des
paroles très fortes en disant nous
demandons-nous l'ukraine de faire partie
de l'union européenne
et d'ailleurs le parlement européen a
fait une standing ovation et beaucoup
d'émotion et à accepter un cette demande
de l'ukraine c'est un événement
extraordinaire par rapport à l'histoire
de l'europe mais ce que je retiens de
ces paroles aujourd'hui c'est qu'il a
dit les principes du traité
constitutionnel de l'union européenne
sont les principes de l'ukraine ça veut
dire l'ukraine est un état nation qui
repose sur une base qui n'est pas
national ethnique comme c'est le cas
pour un empire comme c'est le cas pour
la russie la russie dit vous les
ukrainiens vous faites partie de notre
histoire parce que nous venons de la
même ethnie voyez alors que lui dit nous
nous former un état nation parce que les
principes de justice d'état des droits
de démocratie de solidarité
c'est ça qui nous permet de dépasser le
fait qu'ils aient des russophones des
ukrainophones des orthodoxes de
catholiques et russophone ne veut pas
forcément dire être pro russe non pas du
tout les ukrainiens sont bilingues pour
la plupart simplement il y en a pour qui
la première langue c'est le russe et qui
à l'école apprennent l'ukrainien et
d'autres pour qui la première langue
c'est l'ukrainien et qui par la force
des choses apprennent le russe ils sont
bilingues mais justement on a longtemps
voulu les diviser sur la base de la
langue et eux répondent non ce qui nous
unit est plus important que ce qui nous
divise et ce qui nous unit c'est
précisément les principes de l'union
européenne c'est pour ça qu'on s'est
battu au cours des trois maidan qu'on a
vécu depuis 1991 et c'est pour ça qu'on
demande de faire partie de la grande
famille des des nations européennes et
il a posé cette question au tragique
nous on a fait notre part de chemin
maintenant vous européen fait la vôtre
et c'est pour ça que c'est magnifique
que le parlement européen alors ça va
prendre du temps il va y avoir encore
une décision du conseil européen
de ratification par les états nations ça
va prendre du temps ils veulent
accélérer les choses mais déjà que les
peuples européens savent limbaugh nique
et accepter ça ça va galvaniser
l'ukraine lune et ça va faire un ça va
donner un grand coup au moral de de
vladimir poutine et de sa junte le
ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères
gauthier rybinski dit que l'otan est une
obligation morale est un devoir
politique d'accompagner l'effort
militaire de l'ukraine qu'est ce que ça
signifie car si car si l'otan
intervenait on sait les conséquences
elles pourraient être incontrôlables
c'est vrai mais quand le ministre
ukrainien des affaires étrangères parle
de devoir moral on en est bien là parce
que vous savez que l'otan de par
l'article 5 à un devoir militaire un
devoir opérationnel c'est à dire que si
un pays membre de l'otan est attaqué
tous les autres doivent venir à son
secours et de manière mal militaire mais
c'est vrai que là et je je relève ce que
vous disiez les uns et les autres c'est
vrai que le grand progrès à mon sens
c'est qu'on est en train de sortir d'un
discours qui étaient européens qui
étaient américains qui était un discours
de realpolitik où on penser que vladimir
poutine était accessible à une forme de
raisons qui concernait et bien la
conquête de biens matériels ou des
conquêtes stratégique la crimée l'accès
aux eaux mers chaudes et c'est hélas ce
qui est intéressant c'est que le
politique qui revient à grand à grand
renfort et de manière assez glorieuses
il faut bien dire quand l'union
européenne l'assemblée parlementaire le
parlement dit oui il faut deux intégrés
on va voir dans combien de temps et
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué mais il
faut intégrer l'ukraine parce que
précisément l'ukraine dit ce qu'elle dit
est bien là il y à quelque chose qui est
une forme de tabous brisés et c'est
intéressant de la même manière je
reviens ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure par rapport à l'opinion russe
qui se poseraient la question
effectivement de l'utilité du bien fondé
de la justesse d'agresser des frères
tout le pari de l'avenir et là aussi
c'est à dire de faire en sorte que les
russes ne considère plus forcément là
slavophile y même si elle est
intéressante mais qu'ils se disent il
faut venir en aide et il faut nous mêmes
ou transformés à en une démocratie qui
qui est des idées qui est des valeurs et
là ce sera totalement différent c'est
pour ça que je pense que c'est justement
ça peut affaiblir vladimir poutine vous
savez il faut d'abord considérer ceux
qui ont le cran et le courage de
résister il y en russie quantité de
personnes il y à quelques organes de
presse qui travaillent dans un climat
épouvantable citons les parce qu'ils en
ont besoin que ça ça novaïa gazeta que
ça soit d'acheter la télévision que ça
soit l'écho de moscou la grande radio
sont des gens qui ont un cran formidable
il faut pas l'oublier et ils peuvent
être un jour les illustrations du dollar
évolution que le peuple russe doit
accomplir et c'est pour ça que je
rejoins ce que disait le général
desportes à propos d'un renversement du
régime poutine qu'il faut souhaiter bien
évidemment et qu'il a permettra à la
russie n'ont plus forcément de
s'adresser à un sentiment ou à une fibre
slavophile mais de considérer qu'il est
capital de défendre un pays comme
l'ukraine parce qu'il incarne à mieux
qu'il incarne une raison et un mieux
être aussi potentiel pour la russie qui
se serait débarrassé de vladimir poutine
le mythe de la défense russe a affirmé
que l'opération réussir et jusqu'au bout
jusqu'à ce que les objectifs fixés soit
apte soit atteint il a parlé de nez
dénazification du pays c'est quoi
l'objectif c'est la disparition de
l'ukraine qu'on connaît aujourd'hui pour
vladimir poutine c'est extrêmement
inquiétant moi j'ai vu que l'armée russe
utiliser des armes thermobarique c'est
des armes absolument horrible parce que
l terrifie
lld explosion à la fois thermique et qui
agressent les populations le but c'est
de faire plier le gouvernement
ukrainien mais on sait que le
gouvernement ukrainien ne pliera pas et
surtout que ce gouvernement fantoche
auquel rêvent vladimir poutine pour
remplacer le gouvernement de zielinski
n'a aucune chance de s'imposer ni à kiev
mais je dirais maintenant il ya peu de
chance maintenant pour que ce
gouvernement puisse s'imposer à lougansk
à donetsk voir en crimée parce que il ya
quand même des liens d'amitié qui
existent entre ses habitants de crime et
d'une basse et de kiev et tout le monde
voit avec horreur la le côté sauvage de
cette agression donc là en en
envahissant l'ukraine ou la dîmière
poutine s'est tiré une balle dans le
pied alors le risque malheureusement
c'est que ça va passer par des parts des
images terribles telles que celles qu'on
voit et ça va passer par des
destructions ça va passer par des
réfugiés ça va passer par ddd drame mais
voilà ça n'a aucune chance de de dabou
tirs au but dont parle la mûre l'armée
russe à savoir des nazis fier c'est au
contraire pacifiées voilà au contraire
c'est l'armée russe qui apparaît est
d'ailleurs dans les manifestations qui
ont lieu partout en europe on fait une
identité claire maintenant entre entre
hitler et et poutine poutine poutine a
déjà perdu sa guerre peuvent poutine a
déjà perdu ses objectifs les choses sont
claires il a perdu la guerre de la
communication il a perdu sa guerre tout
court circuit d'abord il a détruit il
est un homme intelligent qu'on a pris
pour un grand sa thèse pendant 22 ans et
qui en cinq jours a détruit tout ce
qu'il avait construit c'était un homme
qui était ami avec israël en même temps
qu'avec l'arabie saoudite qui parlait à
tout le monde avec la chine avec l'inde
et maintenant on le sait tout ça et tout
ça est fini donc il y là il est perdu en
quelques jours il s'est isolé que jamais
aujourd'hui la scène avec jamais donc il
a perdu il appelle au dollar us il n'a
que le bélarus avec lui et là que le
visage illuminé celui-là
alors il ya beaucoup de dettes
mais elle mais ce qui est embêtant c'est
pas parce que vous avez perdu que vous
lâchez si vous voulez et parfois ok j'ai
tout perdu pour avoir tout perdu
continuons et c'est pas impossible
serait il est dans une fuite en avant
vladimir il faut l'arrêter avant et
c'est là où il faudra et c'est pour ça
que le président macro est important que
le président macro et celui probablement
le dirigeant qui en tête qui le connaît
le mieux aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est
pas les américains ils se taisent la
seule chose qu'ont dit les américains
c'est qu'on n'en verra pas le soldat se
battre et depuis monsieur monsieur baden
entend plus que ça c'était une erreur de
communication de la part des états unis
de le dire ça de dire on n'en verra pas
un seul soldat sur sur sur le sol
ukrainien je ne crois pas beaucoup de
gens disent ça mais je ne crois pas au
cdas est tout à fait réaliste de dire
que
l'organisation de l'otan ne prévoit
absolument pas de venir en aide à un
pays qui fait pas partie de l'otan
peut-être at-il dit trop tôt a dit très
doux des vieux titres alors qu'il
fallait lycéens a basculé
je crois que vladimir poutine savez très
bien que les états unis ne défendrait
pas militairement n'enverra pas de
soldats en ukraine en revanche de
l'avoir dit en amont lui permet
aujourd'hui d'expliquer que non il ne
peut pas y aller alors qu'ils diraient
non aujourd'hui il y là il apparaîtrait
comme complètement faible par rapport à
poutine non il apparaît fort et et on
rappelle que les états unis c'est eux
qui arment l'ukraine qui qui envoient
des des missiles sting des lance
missiles stinger qui en qui qui qui
depuis des années des blocs des
centaines de millions de dollars pour
armer l'ukraine donc çà çà çà se déploie
et ça montre que nous c'est maintenant
que l'union européenne ce dimanche
dernier a accepté d'envoyer du matériel
militaire à l'ukraine il ya maintenant
50 millions d'euros c'est inédit
quand la voix de l'amérique elle à gaz
extrêmement faible on n'entend pas la
voix de l'amérique parce que cette
affaire la langue est bien il y avait
une possibilité c'est l'amérique qui
défend la liberté dans le monde quand
même on aurait pu avoir deux mille
soldats envoyés à quinze jours à aa kiev
je dois dire à poutine attention moi j'y
vais c'est pas un pays l'otan mais je
suis là on n'a pas eu je dirais domaine
des mesures très courageuse quand même
je t'envoie les amis l'ont toujours
rappelez-vous en afghanistan ils
envoyaient des stingers l'armée russe
était arrivé etc ils ont quand même
cette habitude de faire combattre par
les autres et ne pas être et grand jeu
sauf sûr c'est que la russie est une
puissance nucléaire il y avait un risque
de dérapage tout ça est vrai tout ça est
vrai mais néanmoins là on envoie des
armes et après on s'en occupe plus
vraiment le problème de la russie en
part des dollars des etats-unis en
particulier aujourd'hui que c'était sec
cette affaire là ils en mettent bien
parce que leur problème c'est pas la
russie c'est la chine comme on le sait
et donc ils ont ils ont ils ont ça est
leur problème c'est que monsieur byden
ne peut pas paraître faible parce que ce
serait un très mauvais signal donné à
monsieur xi il peut pas être au four non
plus parce qu'il peut pas s'engager donc
quelles que sa position ne fait pas
l'unanimité au aux états unis mais c'est
régulier qu'il est très critiquée par
certains républicains notamment ce jeu
joue pas je peux je savoure ce prix mais
la position de bayonne était une
position faible toute façon c'est il a
une il a été élu finalement parra par
très peu de voix je crois que son nombre
de voix qui est inférieur dont deux
voies total mais au fond il a été élu
par les par les quelques ce que les
américains appellent les reinecke de
l'oklahoma et du milieu des états unis
est son problème elle lui aurait on sait
pas comment il va le gérer c'est de pas
laissées train peut être réélu parce que
c'est pas absolument impossible et donc
il est dans cette idée dans ce jeu qui
est qui est un peu compliquée qui le qui
l'empêchent il n'a pas les mains libres
le président des états unis aujourd'hui
à très peu de liberté de manoeuvre parce
que l'intérêt national est purement
domestiques on sait bien qu aux etats
unis la politique extérieure n'est
jamais qu'une variable de la politique
intérieure mais je dirais c'est plus en
plus vrai et cet homme qu'on voit là a
de moins en moins de liberté d'action
politique et j'aimerais qu'on revienne
un peu sur le sur le terrain puisque on
a beaucoup parlé de kiev au début de ce
débat mais l'étau se resserre l'étau
russe se resserre un peu partout kharkiv
est sous les bombes depuis ce matin la
place centrale de la ville vous allez le
voir a été bombardé au moins dix
personnes un bien sûr c'est un bilan
provisoire ont été tués volodymyr
zelensky ya à dénoncer tout à l'heure un
crime de guerre on va on va l'écouter on
en reparle juste après
le bombardement de la place centrale de
kharkiv est une terreur flagrante non
dissimulé personne ne pardonnera
personne n'oubliera cette frappe contre
karkhiv est un crime de guerre c'est du
terrorisme d'état de la part de la
fédération de russie après cela la
russie est manifestement un état
terroriste et doit l'être officiellement
le cil marbot vous l'évoquiez tout à
l'heure la guerre à des règles cette
frappe en plein centre ville de kharkiv
deuxième ville d'ukraine s éteint un
crime de guerre c'est extrêmement
inquiétant c'est pour ça vraiment que
depuis le début comme je me disais tout
à l'heure on répète aux parties au
conflit vraiment l'obligation de
respecter le droit le droit
international humanitaire qui est un peu
le droit du plus faible en l'occurrence
hausse est vraiment protéger les
populations civiles réussir à distinguer
les cibles militaires des cibles civiles
donc c'est bien entendu extrêmement
inquiétant on dialogue à ce moment là en
fait en toute confidentialité avec des
belligérants et nous continue à répéter
malheureusement voilà les obligations
auxquelles chaque partie doit se tenir
et également le problème relève
effectivement lorsque ma les guerres la
guerre les combats arrive en ville ce
sont des besoins humanitaires qui
augmente propre les populations civiles
des problèmes pour se ravitailler et
c'est quoi le type de besoin de ces
populations civiles et les besoins les
plus importants dans l'immédiat
nourriture accès aux soins médicaux
éventuellement s'ils sont blessés de
pouvoir accéder effectivement à des
hôpitaux c'est pour ça que nous au bout
d'un moment ça va être extrêmement
important de pouvoir ravitailler les et
des hôpitaux ont besoin aussi spécifique
pour pouvoir soigner les blessés de
guerre on est vraiment en train de
construire actuellement avec nos
partenaires de la croix rouge la réponse
humanitaire qui va monter on a fait un
appel aujourd'hui aux dons de 250
millions d'euros à se partager en gros
entre l'ukraine où s'arrête le cicr la
croix rouge ukrainien en première ligne
pour venir assister les populations
nourriture eau comme je disais soins
médicaux mais ça va être aussi au niveau
du logement il ya vraiment des besoins
mixte en fonction d'où les personnes
sont bien entendu si les personnes qui
vont être piégés par les combats dans
les villes et également tous les
déplacés internes que nous avons vu
qu'ils se déplacent à travers le le
territoire actuellement et tous les
réfugiés qui sont en train d'arriver
dans les pays limitrophes 660 mille
personnes selon le commissariat aux
réfugiés des centaines de millions de
personnes là qui sont en train de bouger
soit à l'intérieur des terres où est
entendu dans les pays voisins et là nous
sommes vraiment en contact avec la
croix-rouge polonaise et lituanienne
tous les pays limitrophes ils sont en
train de vraiment muscler la réponse à
apporter justement réfugiés qui est qui
qui viennent souvent sans rien et qu'il
va falloir pouvoir assister et voilà
donc l'arrêt pour ceux se montre comme
comme on peut et on n'a pas de boule de
cristal on ne sait pas pendant combien
de temps les des combats vont perdurer
on peut pas vraiment savoir quelles vont
être les besoins immédiats est ce que
sur le plat si le conflit selon vous
risquent de s'enliser est ce qu'on la
guerre s'annonce longue aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui jean castex c'est ce qu'a
dit le président macron sait que ça va
être long parce que quand à un pays
aussi important cherche à envahir le
plus grand pays d'europe l'ukraine en
superficie on peut comprendre que ça va
pas se faire du jour au lendemain et que
il y avait aucune chance pour que le
blitzkrieg fonctionne donc oui ça va
être long simplement plus c'est long et
moi c'est bon pour pour la russie
puisque on va voir le fait que le rouble
davis de 30% le fait que ça va être
difficile de pouvoir retirer de l'argent
à la banque de 2,2 tout ça tout ça va
rendre complètement impopulaire en
russie le conflit donc qu'avec le temps
joue pour l'ukraine mais malheureusement
pendant ce temps là il ya des drames
incroyable des écoles qui sont bombardés
des hôpitaux qui sont bombardés pendant
ce temps là des enfants qui ont été tués
alors qu'ils ont été tués c'est
absolument terrible
gauthier rybinski l'onu demande
d'urgence 1 27 milliard de dollars pour
l'aide humanitaire à l'ukraine
ça va suffire tout ça pour un conflit
qui risque de durer encore le suspense
on entend par là l'homme serait plus à
vie et quand j'ai pas de deux durs de
conflit long aussi on parle de combien
de temps on parle de moi
d'année la guerre afghanistan duré 20
ans donc on sait ce que c'est les
guerres les guerres dans au sein des
populations parce que ça pourrait
devenir une guerre au sein des
populations j'ai rêvé dur dur d années
et on en sort toujours perdants ça on le
sait oui ce que je voulais ajouter par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit messieurs
concernant les états unis le problème
auquel on fait face c'est que des
organisations comme l'otan ou l'union
européenne ont été créés dans l'idée du
droit de la paix bien sûr de la défense
de la paix et l'idée du droit et que on
est en quelque sorte prisonnier de ce
droit quand on fasse on a quelqu'un qui
ne respecte pas le bafouent qui le foule
aux pieds et qu'à partir de là bien sûr
on peut dire qu'il faut sortir de ce2
ce2 second en quelque sorte aussi c'est
ce qui a été fait au moment de la sphère
du kosovo et des bombardements sur sur
belgrade mais tout tout le danger de
cela c'est non seulement de sortir du
droit quand on a en face une puissance
nucléaire mais aussi de faire comprendre
aux populations qui sont valides qu'elle
soit européenne ou américaine très
frileuse et qu'ils ont l'impression que
tout ça est très loin même en france on
a l'impression que c'est très loin de
leur faire comprendre que sortir de ses
gonds pour défendre ce qu'il y à
défendre là c'est à dire pas une
mainmise territoriale même si bien sûr
il ya des intérêts stratégiques et de
dire c'est nous qui sommes là la part à
la place des ukrainiens c'est la même
chose quand on entend ici pardonnez-moi
mais 30 on entend ici certains militants
anti vaccins par exemple qui vous
reprochent qui reproche à la police
d'être victime de violences policières
c'est vrai mais regardez comment ceux
qui manifestent à moscou sont embarqués
dans les fourgons de police on laisse
aussi sonne dans des toiles de jute et
ensuite ce qu'on entend aujourd'hui
c'est que la nouvelle législation est
tout à fait adaptées peut-être pas tout
de suite mais dans un temps assez proche
d'eux est tout à fait adapté pour
précisément placé ces gens qui ont
simplement émis des protestations en
prison ou devant un tribunal dont on
sait il est acquis par avance d'un
tribunal fantoche là aussi c'est un
simulacre de tribunal d'auch qui
condamnera des manifestants à des peines
de prison égales ou avaient même changé
la donne et de 20 ans voilà alors
j'attends pour les agents de l'étranger
ou
qui peut la borne l'effacement il est
très facilement et on peut considérer
juste avant que des manifestants
atterriront dans cette catégorie un
dernier mot il nous reste très peu de
temps moi je voudrais parler d'un homme
d'un ukrainien on parle beaucoup de
zelensky et c'est normal c'est un
symbole mais il ya une autre figure
ukrainienne dont on parle peu mais qui
moi me bouleverse et un chanteur qui
s'appelle va car tchouk et qui est le
chanteur un peu comme le johnny hallyday
des ukrainiens quoi l'ailé depuis plus
de vingt ans on écoute ma carte tout le
groupe au kernel zahi la venue faire des
tournées aussi en france et va car
tchouk il a diffusé sur facebook des
photos où on le voit avec des armes dans
la forêt avec un groupe de personnes qui
résistent et appelant l'ensemble de la
nation a résisté la carte succès celui
où quand c'est de la journée de
l'indépendance nationale qui réunit des
foules entières à la télévision donc
voilà c'est là la nation ukrainienne
de la résistance est un symbole de
résistance de liberté de dignité de et
de force puissante de l'ukraine merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre c'est la fin
de ce débat consacré à cette guerre en
ukraine rester avec nous sur france24
l'information continue